bonjour alexis et merci d'être en direct
à coup ce matin sur rtl france alors
emmanuel macron a dévoilé son plan de
retour à la normale si on peut dire est
ce que aujourd'hui on y voit un peu plus
clair c'est suffisant pour que ton
puisse organiser
alors oui c'est suffisant mais sans
doute pas nécessaire puisque on voit
bien que là il y à l'idée de donner des
dates de rassurer les commerçants les
entrepreneurs les restaurateurs et tous
ses secteurs de la société qui sont
fermés depuis de trop longues aux
nombreux mois et donc on donne des dates
en disant voilà on a un plan en
plusieurs phases avec à chaque fois
trois semaines pour voir si ça
fonctionne ou pas ou si jamais le virus
reprendrai avec toujours cette idée de
frein d'urgence un territorialisée où on
pourrait continuer d'avoir des mesures
coercitives dans certains départements
régions si le besoin se faisait jour
donc ça permet évidemment à beaucoup de
secteurs de s'organiser
l'été arrive c'est la saison des
festivals bien sûr les restaurateurs
mais quand on entend dire qu'il n'y aura
plus de couvre-feu fin juin ça ne veut
pas dire pour autant que les boîtes de
nuit vont réouvrir par exemple pour eux
c'est le flou total ils ont été les
grands oubliés de ce plan de réouverture
beaucoup d'établissements de nuit ont
déjà fermé certains sont en procédure de
liquidation judiciaire et beaucoup vont
sans doute fermé donc il ya des secteurs
qui ne se remettront jamais de toute
façon de cette crise qu vide
et puis il ya la question de la gestion
au jour le jour de l'épidémie de sa
progression
on apprend que le variant indien sai est
sur le sol national
évidemment et la vaccination qui
continuent d'avoir des couacs avec
astrazeneca on l'a entendu et puis des
doses qu'ils trouvent pas preneurs
encore donc beaucoup de volonté dans la
façon dont les mollets de la coupe
présente ce plan mais à voir s'il pourra
être mis en oeuvre en temps et en heure
et puis des questions qui se posent
le pass sanitaire pourquoi comment quel
sera le débat de bioéthique à
l'assemblée nationale pourquoi le
vouloir l'imposer sur les événements où
nous serons nombreux
on voit bien qu'on pousse se passait ni
terre alors que les français sont
majoritairement contre 1 au conseil
économique social et environnemental
le vote des français consultés en ligne
était à 70% contre le pass sanitaires et
on voit bien qu'on veut imposer ce pass
sanitaires aux citoyens français coûte
que coûte justement se passe à lithaire
on a l'impression qu'ils risquent un
petit peu voilà d'être accueillis de
manière différente aussi bien par les
professionnels que les particuliers
certains sont d'accord d'autres non mais
finalement ce pas sanitaire ce n'est pas
une forme de fichage c'est une forme de
fichage et bioéthique puisque il vous
demande de vous présenter en tant que
non porteurs de virus en tant que
vacciner ou non
donc il ya le risque évidemment de la
rupture de l'égalité entre les citoyens
entre ceux qui ont eu accès à la
vaccination
ceux qui ne souhaitent pas se faire
vacciner donc un danger réel en fait de
scission qui n'est pas pris en compte
alors je veux bien que ça rassure
beaucoup en disant ah oui mais comme ça
on est sûr de ne pas l'attraper etc
c'est faux puisque pour une tout le
problème du pass sanitaire c'est qu'il
repose sur un test ou une vaccination de
la vaccination on ne sait pas quelle est
la durée d'immunisation qu'elle profère
et quant aux tests il faudra en faire a
quasiment tout le temps pour être sûr de
pouvoir aller quelque part où ailleurs
donc on est vraiment dans quelque chose
d'assez fou qui est en train d'ouvrir
les vannes d'une société du bio contrôle
total à la chinoise où vous êtes bons
mauvais citoyens et vous ai vus
quotidiennement sur les réseaux sociaux
et sur ce que vous faites dans la vie
réelle c'est quelque chose qui est en
train d'avancer à bas bruit dans notre
démocratie et je crois qu'il faut être
extrêmement vigilant et ne pas prendre
ça pour une mesure sanitaire parce que
derrière on sait bien que ces mesures
aléatoire mal réfléchie bricoler dans
l'urgence spf souvent dû geler
malheureusement et s'inscrire dans la
loi alors toutes les annonces qui ont
été faites par le président de la
république sont parues dans la presse
régionale pourtant emmanuel macron a
pris la parole plusieurs fois pendant
cette crise sanitaire pour faire des
annonces au français est ce que
finalement il a voulu renouer avec une
france des territoires et ce qu'ils
préparent finalement la campagne
présidentielle 2022 oui il ne s'en cache
pas d'ailleurs dans cette interview à la
presse régionale il est présent
sur toutes les unes de la presse
quotidienne régionale aujourd'hui et il
le dit dans cette interview qu'il va
reprendre son bâton de pèlerin pour
aller tâter le pouls des territoires
donc clairement il est en campagne il va
viser bien sûr les territoires après les
régionales qui risque d'être une défaite
pour son parti la république en marche
qui ne met pas d'ailleurs en avant le
président sur les affiches de campagne
il faut le préserver de cette défaite
électorale
donc après cette défaite lui prendra son
bâton de pèlerin pour aller tâter le
pouls des deux territoires sachant que
plus de cent mille français eux ont
perdu le pour pas toujours ils sont
morts de cette gestion de crise du coc
vide et puis l'a dit également
il va préparer une grande concertation
pour l'été alors ça c'est son truc
emmanuel macron la grande concertation
le grand débat grand blabla la grande
marche
l'idc d'enfumer les français avec un
exercice des changes tout à fait
orienter un de manière politique pour
pouvoir rebondir préparé un programme et
se représenter devant les français avec
un bilan qui restera extrêmement maigre
pour ne pas dire nulles voire impossible
à défendre ça c'est dans les mois qui
viennent ça dépendra bien sûr de la
reprise ou non de l'épidémie à l'automne
et de la gestion de la au delà de la
crise sanitaire de la crise économique
pour de nombreux commerces et
entreprises qui vont devoir mettre la
clé sous la porte
merci beaucoup alexis à poulain d'avoir
réagi ce matin sur notre antenne